ça paraissait parfait voilà j'avais plus
besoin de prendre deux trains m réveillé
à 5 heures du matin donc ce monsieur
voilà il me faisait à manger je pouvais
jouer à la console nintendo à l'époque
mais voilà chaque soir c'était c'était
une bagarre à une bagarre tous les soirs
et il a réussi le dernier soir à faire
ce qu'il avait à ce qu'ils avaient à
faire et voilà c'est quelque chose
vraiment comme je dis dans ce monde
lettres noires c'est déjà un des
avantages grandir dans une cité basse et
pas de jouer les les gangsters ou les
caïds c'est une question de survie c'est
pour ça que j'ai horreur de ces
personnes de ces célébrités qui disent
oui j'étais jeune un quartier non et
puis abus sexuels à l'âge de 13 ans
c'est un traumatisme mais je me suis
voilà je suis une victime mais j'ai
horreur que les personnes disent que tu
es une victime parce que j'ai rien lâché
je me suis servi de ça et ça m'a
construit et quelquefois voilà j'ai eu
des impulsions et agressif ou pas faire
confiance à l'autorité parce que je ne
rendais pas compte qu'en fait ce
traumatisme à ma forme et qui je suis
qui je suis devenu aujourd'hui mais vous
savez que ce que ce que vous écrivez
danser c'est aujourd'hui de voir une
telle star comme vous en parlions pas
c'est tellement important pour tous les
jeunes et je pense que c'est pour ça
aussi vous avez fait ce livre faisant
par l'onu pour tous les jeunes qui nous
regardent et qui six mois j'ai peur d'en
parler fait peur de le dire j'ai honte
d'en parler et de voir quelqu'un comme
vous qui a une carrière incroyable voilà
qui est vous êtes respecté par tous
c'est vrai que ça joue énormément et je
pense que c'est très très important
vraiment ce que vous avez mais je pense
que cyril ces personnes il faut pas dire
pardon mondiaux pas triste a été très
courageux d'en parler c'est pas une
question de courage c'est d'être prêt
mentalement ça te parler aux bonnes
personnes moi par exemple j'ai rencontré
la femme de ma vie margot qu'a réussi à
balayer toute cette toxiques masculinité
conte à moi j'ai grandi avec mon père
pleurer c'est un signe de faiblesse
maintenant j'arrive à peu à pleurer de
joie et voilà je pense qu'il faut un
déclic c'est pour ça ces personnes-là
jeu il faut pas les pousser à l'efo
parler faut parler moi j'ai fait j'ai
parlé devant plus de 800 personnes à
manchester il y avait une dame de 50 ans
et puis voilà justin sur l'auto graffet
fond en larmes je lui dis mais qu'est ce
qui est madame dit non monsieur evra
voile à l'âge de 9 ans je me suis fait
voler violer par mon propre frère je
n'ai jamais dit à mon père je n'ai
jamais dit à ma mère je n'ai jamais
jamais jamais même parlé à mon mari et
mes enfants et et voilà depuis que vous
avez parlé je vous ai vu sur scène
bajeux je sais même pas pourquoi je
m'ouvre à vous et c'est pour ça que je
me dis aujourd'hui ben voila j'ai tapé
derrière un ballon ça mais je peux
donner beaucoup plus tuer les gens ils
me disent qu'est ce que tu fais après ta
retraite bas je suis heureux je veux me
rapprocher des gens et leur donner
espoir
en plus vos parents ils avaient
confiance en ce directeur a c'est ça le
pire ça arrive c'est pour ça parce que
je voulais en parler parce que c'est
vrai que sa fille son enfant ont fuit
son enfant il ya plein de gens qui nous
regardent qui se disent pour confiner
entre enfants on est on est on se dire
voilà on est en confiance on dit les
bien au contraire ça lui permet de
réaliser ses rêves et derrière c'est un
cauchemar non c'est un cauchemar moi je
pense le match le plus difficile
que j'ai eue de toute ma vie c'est voilà
c'est à 40 ans de venir à paris et est
de le dire à sa mère parce que je cache
pas que ce livre il était terminée
depuis quatre ans et j'avais fini
j'avais pas fait cette révélation et
quand j'ai parlé avec margot voilà j'ai
dit bah je me suis ouvert finalement une
personne moi je vais je vais aussi
l'écrire dans mon livre ma mère je me
souviens quand je les ai vus à paris bon
elle était effondrée en larmes il est où
ce monsieur comment il s'appelle mais
j'ai tellement effacé que j'ai même pu
son visage dans ma tête mais aujourd'hui
ma mère me dit surtout le met pas dans
le livre j'ai dit si maman parce que
c'est pas pour moi c'est pour laisser
pour les autres en faire assez pour les
autres personnes qui ont déjà été
victimes
d'agressions sexuelles vous parliez tout
à l'heure 10 et tous les soirs c'était
la bagarre et puis le dernier soir
voilà pas si
ce drame qu'est ce qui se passe et le
soir ben ils venaient dans ma chambre
dans le noir toujours le même rituel il
essayait de me toucher donc voilà je
mettais des coups mais j'avais j'avais
13 ans et j'attache et je tenais mon
pantalon pour me toucher quand même et
puis il faisait ce qu'il avait fait au
bord du lit et j'ai même carrément un
jour pris les lacets de mes chaussures
est attaché ça c'est ce que vous dit
autour de matin c'est ce que je dis en
détail voilà après attacher les la c2a
tâches exercées à votre pantalon pour
pas que le directeur paul baysse voilà
exactement et puis après voilages
explique en détail dans le livre sur ce
qu'il est ce qu'il a fait mais à
l'époque après j'ai voilà c'était comme
un choc et je me disais mais qu'est ce
qui se passe parce que je n'avais pas
déjà un rapport avec la sexualité mais
c'est vrai que ma mère
je fais que lui dire pardon pardon à
dinan tu doit excuser la personne et je
veux rajouter aussi à l'âge de 24 ans je
me suis senti comme un lâche parce que
la police m'a contacté et m'a dit
monsieur devra écouter on a des plaintes
contre ce buzz avec ce monsieur et je
sais on sait que vous avez dormi chez ce
monsieur et j'ai dit non et après on
vous êtes sûrs et j'ai dit non parce
qu'en fait c'est pas une question de
aude mais tu tu as tellement envie
d'effacer ça c'est quand j'ai raccroché
ben voila j'ai vécu toute cette vie avec
ce poids et quand les gens me disaient
mais pas très c'était un bon gars mais
moi j'ai toujours eu le sentiment
d'avoir abandonné ses enfants parce que
des fois c'est pas pour c'est pas pour
soi même mais c'est et après tu trouves
comme excuse oui mais de façon pas
triste et une star et donc voilà c'est
mieux parce que qu'est-ce que les gens
ils ont repensé mais non c'est pas ça la
vraie un vrai show c'est parce que tu as
honte et tapadas pas envie d'en parler
en fait ça t'agace quand les gens
entendent ensuite en par vous a pesé
tout au long de votre carrière
tout ce que vous avez connu vous êtes
avait gelé ni intel réserve avec le beau
palmarès du football français s'est fait
une énorme star du foot est ce que vous
aviez toujours ça en fait ça et j'avais
passant en tête mais ça ça a bloqué
toutes mes émotions j'ai pas honte de
dire que quelques fois j'ai gagné des
trophées et je faisais même semblant
d'être content devant la caméra voilà ça
veut dire toutes ces émotions d'être
triste mais j'ai perdu mon frère j'ai
des frac et j'ai des amis qui sont fait
tuer mais je n'avais pas conscience
parce que je réalisais pas tout était
bloqué mon émotion de tristesse j'ai
plusieurs personnes qu'ils aiment et
patrice des machines de guerre turcs
tutu trans aériens étaient des costauds
parce que voilà gt gt un robot j'étais
un robot c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui ok
quoi c'était s'était bloquée ces femmes
marveaux maintenant qu'ils me disent mes
pattes il ya un problème tu es un super
gars mais quand tu t'énerves cc profond
c'est vraiment un les yeux tu tu envie
de tuer et à une colère et puis après
voilà quand on a regardé une émission
sur les pédophiles et elle a vu mon
visage et qui a complètement changé elle
m'a dit qu'est ce qui se passe je dis
rien indice il ya quelque chose et puis
là je me suis lâché et je vais raconter
et fondu en larmes et puis à l'arrivée
voilà c'est fou c'est fou parce que
c'est vrai que on nous de l'extérieur on
s'est réconciliés c'est vrai que patrice
et vous voyez moi j'ai vu que j'ai vu
tous les trophées vous avez gagné j'ai
vu une idée c'est quelqu'un voilà qui
qui qui n'aiment pas être trop expressif
sur ça mais en fait c'est qu'il y avait
vraiment un truc qui vous ok c'est
synchro est maintenant qu'on sait pas ce
que c'est mais même moi même je me moi
je mettais tout sur le compte du géant
du quartier donc c'est comme ça dans le
quartier c'est une question de survie il
faut toujours se rebeller et cetera mais
c'était plus profond que ça et
aujourd'hui il se sent libéré non libéré
heureux moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui je
suis quelqu'un je vis dans le présent si
tu penses au passé tu vas vivre avec des
regrets aux futurs tu avis vague de
l'anxiété donc voilà je vis le moment
présent aujourd'hui je suis vraiment
heureux d'être en france mais avant tout
et franchement ça me fait un énorme
plaisir que je suis ici avec parmi vous
et donc voilà je suis un homme de paix